so what's the deal with this shot in
this episode of Dragon Ball super where
Frieza is spelled with two e's well the
short answer is that Frieza spelled f r
i e z e is kind of a dumb translation of
his name because his entire family's
name are puns of cold things Frieza is
obviously a Pawn on freezer in Japanese
it's just the word freezer but with the
last syllable replaced with an a sound
it's the same situation with cooler or
King cold and now I don't know about you
but I have never been an electronic
store and seen a frieser for sale
FUNimation clearly also thinks the
classic Cinderella song is
bibbidi-bobbidi Boo with two U's and
don't even get me started on the Ginyu
Force how many of you know that this
guy's name is a pun on yogurt who what
FUNimation is going to the store to buy
yo guldoort